Shhh...
♪ Could you hear that? ♪
♪ No, no, you've got to listen closer. ♪
♪ The Dandelion speaks. ♪
♪ Don't laugh, she's got some things to teach us. ♪
♪ It's the small things like us. ♪
♪ We come together to make big things. ♪
♪ Like the baseball game. ♪
♪ It's not just one it's everyone. ♪
♪ And to be fair ♪
♪ we don't own this ground, ♪
♪ Charlie Brown. ♪
♪ We share it. ♪
♪ So whoa up!  Slow down! There's life on the mound? Can you hear the sound? ♪
♪ It's the small things, Charlie Brown. ♪
♪ Can't you see yoursef right there. That's you, alone, you're a lonely flower. ♪
♪ But a field of us you know. We make a team and that's our power ♪
♪ so be aware of where you step and what and who you might be stepping on. ♪
♪ Look up. Look now. So huge. So wow. Let me break it down. ♪
♪ Little droplets make big clouds. ♪
♪  It's the small things, Charlie Brown. ♪
♪ Lots and lots of the tiniest dots can make shapes. ♪
♪ Even faces when viewed far away. ♪
♪ And the quietest voice can cut through the noise. ♪
♪ When you're speaking...♪
♪ The truth. ♪
♪ Look up. Look down. ♪
♪ The sky and the ground. ♪
♪  Getting louder now. ♪
♪ The voice of the bravest flower. ♪
♪ Too small to hear without. ♪
♪ Some perspective Charlie Brown. ♪
♪ Do the right thing. Are you with me Charlie Brown? ♪